kourtney and i are caught him in the
back leg do you say it's planned I just
want you called on you turn your light
oh we never really know what to say
khloe kardashian had a hard time keeping
up with the 2019 People's Choice Awards
[Music]
on Sunday night the family took home the
best reality show award for Keeping Up
with the Kardashians thank you guys so
much this this means so much cuz you
know you guys the fans voted for this
and Khloe also won best reality star
though Lee Kardashian is also winning
tonight for the reality star of 2019
but when Khloe Kourtney Kim and their
mom Kris Jenner got up to accept the
award only Kim and Kris spoke we're just
so glad that we're still entertaining 18
seasons later so thank you well Coco's
fans weren't too happy about that and
hit up social media to let her know they
were totally bummed out that they had
voted her to win and she didn't
acknowledge the honor on stage Chloe
responded to all the chatter on Twitter
saying to one fan quote it's so beyond
loud in there I had no idea I won an
individual award until we walked off
stage I feel so badly right now I am so
fun grateful and appreciative I can't
believe I didn't say anything but I
didn't hear that I won until after and
when another fan told commenters to calm
down writing nerves are a real thing
Chloe replied nerves yes but I literally
didn't know until after lol I still feel
so badly about it I love you guys so
much just so everybody knows it's so
awkward like when you go on stage I know
Kim
gee and she takes over and she will talk
Courtney and I are kind of in the back
like hey and if that weren't enough
Chloe also explained the whole sitch on
her instace Tori but we just want you to
know that we do know how to speak we
just get a little nervous and in true
Kardashian fashion Kim made sure to show
her love and support for Chloe and her
big win on Instagram - oh he's gonna get
her moment guys she won reality star of
the year and so they kind of put it with
the family one but this woman deserves a
moment yeah well Chloe got her moment
but what about those rumors that Kourt
wants to leave the show well
ét recently caught up with the famous
sisters and they set the record straight
you mentioned that you might be ready to
say goodbye to Keeping Up with the
Kardashians
where are you out on that I'm just
decided to spend more time as a mom and
you know put more of my energy there and
still but I'm not saying goodbye right
but I think you'll have to see more of
it on the new season season 18 just
crazy isn't airing yet but it's being
filmed okay and currently do you want in
this room do you think the show can
continue going if you lose a sister yeah
I mean we definitely love Courtney we
will miss Courtney and whatever she
decides to do but people come people go
all the time this family we feel like
it's a revolving door
so Courtney might leave this week she'll
be back they all come back
something tells me courts not going
anywhere but you can count on et to make
sure you're the first to know all the
breaking Kardashian news so make sure to
keep it locked right here until next
time I'm Hallie Stephens bye for now
[Music]